c'est vrai que ya une question qui
revient et comme on sait les proches de
fabien monte envoyé de mot ils demandent
de vous demander pourquoi il ya une
peine si longue de 20 ans réduite
réduite à 16 ans et huit mois pour bonne
conduite
alors on a parlé de la durée de la peine
tout à l'heure la situation géographique
de la turquie fait que le trafic de
produits stupéfiants est pénalisée de
manière très dure c'est une obligation
parce que nous sommes sur les voies de
trafic international
ce qu'on nous a dit oui donc ce détenu
ayant peut-être à la suite d'une erreur
on ne sait pas apparemment commander une
grande quantité de ce produit n'a pas pu
donc convaincre les tribunaux que cette
énorme quantité est sain consommation la
personnel c'est de là que donc son
jugement
avec une peine qui correspond à un
trafiquant de produits stupéfiants a dû
être décidée par le tribunal
mais je ne je ne connais pas les détails
du jugement
le sujet dont nous avons parlé c'est sa
demande de transfèrement
justement avoir parlé dans un instant
mais est-ce qu'il est victime on a pris
on l'a vu hier il est victime de
violence en prison à cause de ça de sa
religion de son orientation sexuelle
alors je n'ai pas cette information
détaillée l'information que dans je
dispose c'est que un codétenu lui a
malheureusement c'est regrettable
infligé une violence je n'ai pas
c'est ce que nous a dit son avocate hier
une casserole show de verser de l'eau
chaude sur sur lui pendant qu'il dormait
ça vous l'avocate a plus de détails il
alors que je n'ai pas tous les détails
mais et donc je ne sais pas non plus
exactement quelles étaient les
motivations du codétenu
l'essentiel c'est que transféré dans une
autre prison
le co détenu a dû rendre des comptes et
a reçu une peine pour cette violence est
donc monsieur azoulay a été transféré
dans une autre prison où il est beaucoup
plus isolé
donc il ne il n'a aucun risque de
rencontrer une nouvelle fois ce type de
violence